a new gpu is launching will you be lucky
enough to get one before they're gone
what do you mean one of the specs
it's a new gpu you have to buy it right
you'll have to forgive me for being a
little jaded at this point it's tough to
truly get excited about these launches
and
this one's especially tough for me
because amd's pulling out all the stops
to cost down the new rx 6500 xt
with 16 rdna2 compute units this thing
isn't much more powerful on paper than
amd's new ryzen 6000 mobile apus is
there anything to be excited about here
or does amd just think you'll buy
anything at this point i think you'll
buy this segue to our sponsor though
privacy.com lets you shop online with
virtual credit cards that offer way more
security and control than conventional
cards click the link in description to
get five dollars to spend on your first
purchase when you sign up below
[Music]
how do you make a gpu that's affordable
in these dark times according to amd
first you slash the number of compute
units video memory and memory interface
compared to even a 5 year old gpu then
you cut from 16 pci express gen 3 lanes
to 4 gen 4 lanes for half the total
bandwidth
finally and this step is important
you remove the media engines encoder
blocks and all but two of the display
outputs one hdmi 2.1 port and one
displayport 1.4
yes this gpu has a lower transistor
count than the rx 570 a card that kinda
sucked on its own although that's not to
say that this has no tricks up its
sleeve the core clocks are cranked up
past eleven with peak boost getting
shockingly close to three gigahertz
what's more the more efficient rd and 2
architecture on tsmc's n6 process and
this is the first gpu using it to make
it to market
makes for a graphics card that's less
power hungry than that old card albeit
just by about 40 watts or so from the
spec sheet alone the rx 6500 xt looks
more like an energy efficient rx 580
which
isn't a great sign for what is supposed
to be a 200 gpu in 2022
granted with inflation the rx 570 is
actually closer in price but this isn't
a huge performance per dollar
improvement in the span of five years
at least on paper we've gathered an
array of old and new gpus including the
rx 580 in order to put the amd's
performance claims to the test
it's worth mentioning that amd's target
audience is folks with gpu several
generations old so our test rig is
actually giving it the best possible
scenario to stretch his legs
your mileage will surely vary and it
looks like it varies for the rx 6500
xt's gaming performance too f1 2021
starts off with some pretty low
performance for amd's new gpu reaching
less than 75 percent of the performance
of the rx 580 from 2017. i reran this
bench a bunch because it doesn't make
any sense but
that's what i got
things get even worse when we enable ray
tracing where just 16 ray accelerators
isn't nearly enough to keep frame rates
playable in a title like this
remember the rx 6600 has less than twice
the compute units but that card performs
nearly three times faster it's possible
that video memory is a bottleneck here
which really shows its face in far cry 6
where the game itself even straight up
says that every preset but 1080p low is
more than the gpu's frame buffer can
handle surprisingly the performance at
1080p high doesn't tank
it's just enough to squeeze by
and only the rx 6600 outperforms it here
when we turn on ray tracing though yup
there's your vram bottleneck right there
told you it was marginal to be clear
guys that you're not going to want to
run anything raytrace with this class of
gpu without running some kind of
upscaling algorithm like amd's fidelity
effects super resolution
and even then it's probably a bad idea
these rt tests are all about the
relative performance versus the rx 6600
rather than some kind of endorsement or
lack thereof forza horizon 4 brings some
more good news for the rx 6500 xt though
the medium preset easily fits into
memory so we see performance unequaled
by any other gpu save it's bigger
brother this carries over to hitman 3
too although there's a big asterisk that
needs to be thrown over this one
these numbers are for the second run of
the benchmark the game hitch is bad on
the first run
every time and that's a problem
i think this is a result of memory
bandwidth being just so low because once
the assets are in memory everything's
fine streaming in textures and assets
really hammers the 64-bit memory bus now
amd claims the effective memory
bandwidth is up to 231 gigabytes per
second but the problem with this number
is that it's using the infinity cache
which is ridiculously fast by comparison
the real bandwidth is 144 gigabytes per
second and that is rough it's below the
rx 580.
that's why it's chugging it's filling
the small infinity cache and then
dumping it out the ram as fast as it can
and it's just not fast enough
all of these settings were fully within
amd's guidance by the way finally cs go
is a title that's very banned with
hungry as we discovered in our recent
gpu splitting exploration and it's
confirmed big time here 16 megs of
infinity cash isn't enough and it falls
behind even the rx 580 in terms of
minimum frame rates which is made even
worse by the 6500 xt's higher average
fps that higher variation will feel like
stutters in game and can lead to missed
shots or worse it's not a great
experience
productivity isn't this class of gpu's
forte but amd had a pretty good run at
the top of the charts back in the day
blender is
not good the new hip api support does
its job with the rx 6600 but the 6500 xt
only beats the rx 580
because that card is no longer supported
while it beats out the gtx 1660 in
photoshop it loses to everything else
and every other test with substantially
less performance in davinci resolve
likely thanks to its 4 gigabyte frame
buffer indigo benchmark shows it beating
out its ancestor pretty soundly but
every other card does too so it's not a
great showing overall
mind you all of these cards cost a
fortune on the street by comparison but
the gtx 1660 launched at 219 so it's
really a loss for amd the 6500 xt is not
something someone with a card in this
class would want to upgrade to for
productivity instead you should upgrade
to a water bottle from ltt store.com
unlike gpu vram we don't charge for
extra capacity
if you're looking for an upgrade for an
old pc with this class of gpu as amd
intends chances are you only have four
or six cores at best and you're probably
running pci express gen 3. this card has
4 gen 4 lanes which is fine in a gen 4
board but in a gen 3 board that's half
the bandwidth which might not be so fine
that's a bottleneck although whether
it'll be a problem depends on how weak
your cpu is the bigger problem for
potential upgraders is that there's no
hardware video encoding support so
streaming has to be done entirely on the
cpu cores or integrated graphics if you
got them
this might not be such a big deal with
simpler esports titles that don't take
full advantage of more than a couple of
cores but
if you're a budding streamer looking to
stream all of your gameplay you'll
probably want to look elsewhere or else
play older or very simple titles now as
with any of these lower end gpus without
founders edition style cards thermals
are going to vary from design to designs
and there's no reference cooler to
compare against so take this one with
some salt our xfx quicksilver 210 cards
dual fan layout seems to be a little bit
overbuilt for this gpu with the hotspot
never reading beyond 75 degrees except
for a brief spike while rendering the
initial loading screen
the rx 6600 happens to share the same
cooler and it reaches just past 80
degrees throughout the run
i wouldn't be surprised if somebody were
to make a single slot variation of this
card particularly seeing how there's
only two display outputs to work around
power consumption is where things get
very interesting as it's almost a linear
drop from the 28 compute units on the rx
6600 power draw only briefly breaks the
100 watt mark while rendering the
loading screen and settles in at an
average around 80 watts during the run
proper now this is the default power
target for this card but the fact that
it remains at max core clocks near 2.9
gigahertz is impressive
that said if amd had shaved off just
five watts more power consumption they
could have been the only modern gpu with
no pci express power requirements at the
end of the day
the rx 6500 xt is a gpu for the
desperate plain and simple
it trains blows well enough to work out
to roughly equal the gtx 1660 or 1070 in
gaming which is great but it falls
behind those older cards anywhere four
gigabytes of video memory is too little
and the unfortunate reality is
this is already a problem for amd's own
guidance heck it was a problem for the
rx 580 nobody wanted the 4 gig version
for 200 back in 2017
and it's only going to get worse from
here for an extra 100 bucks or so the rx
6600 represents shockingly close to
double the performance
if of course you could buy one at msrp i
mean it feels
kind of wrong to call that card or even
its nvidia equivalent a good value but
this is the world we inhabit today the
rx 6500 xt really could have been
something special if amd hadn't
brutalized it to meet that 199 dollar
price point at least these are using new
manufacturing capacity unlike some of
nvidia's other upcoming gpus but the rtx
3050 is going to come in at a 50 premium
with eight gigs of faster video memory a
full media engine and more than two
display outputs which makes it pretty
compelling on that basis alone imo
get subscribed by the way because we're
going to have a full review of that card
ready for its launch too
i'm left with a sour taste in my mouth
not because amd cut the card down but
because quite frankly i would recommend
waiting until the rtx 3050 launches to
make your decision on whether to buy
this thing but because of the current
market situation the reality is that you
don't have that long you might not even
be able to find one as of right now
thanks to miners scalpers and desperate
gamers alike i do wonder what amd's
margins on this thing are because it's a
sure thing they'll sell out just like i
sell them for sponsors like hellofresh
thanks to hellofresh for sponsoring this
video time for a healthy new year's
resolution hellofresh is here to help
you hit your healthy goals with hello
fresh you get fresh pre-proportioned
ingredients and seasonal recipes
delivered right to your door they create
delicious step-by-step recipes every
week including calorie smart carb smart
and family friendly options they source
fresh pre-portioned ingredients in
recycled content packaging so you can
waste less and eat more sustainably and
if you're looking to save time cooking
they even have 20-minute meals and low
prep options keeping on your resolutions
is hard enough so let hellofresh deliver
help through delicious meals right to
your door go to hellofresh.com and use
code linus tech tip 16 for up to 16 free
meals and three surprise gifts that's
hellofresh.com promo code
linustechtips16.
thanks for watching guys go check out
our recent overview of andy's other ces
announcements for more on what to expect
from team red in 2022 there's a lot of
cool stuff coming